well one of Manhattan's most iconic
hotels is giving an early check-in to
illegal immigrants the Roosevelt opens
it opened its doors to 20 busloads of
illegals
as the city grapples with the influx of
post title 42 it comes as City Business
Leaders now warn that summer tourism
could become a hot mess if Asylum
Seekers take over too many rooms in the
city here with reaction Queens chamber
of commerce president Tom Gretch Tom
thanks for being here you know the
Roosevelt's just two Avenues and two
blocks from here
it's become the Hub I think they call it
the Asylum Seeker arrival Center what do
you make of how this is unfolding in New
York City
uh good morning and thanks so much for
having me it truly is a mess right now
but I think at least at this point we've
got a centralized location not too far
not only from your offices but also from
the Port Authority Bus Terminal that we
can at least have a sense of of control
and understanding of what some of the
needs are as we continue to get
inundated with these with these folks
from our Southern borders
but Tom I mean New York City is famously
a sanctuary City and it has said you
know come one come all and Texas and
other states are effectively saying okay
live up to your word I mean mayor Adams
said recently hotels of all the hotels
willing to take illegals
um 50 of those are filled up by that
population at this point it just doesn't
feel sustainable
yeah I agree and I understand I mean the
saying goes in the Statue of Liberty
give us your tired you're poor and so we
live up to those ideals but the issue
not necessarily is between Texas and New
York I think the issue Falls square at
the feet of the Congress both parties as
well as President Biden to allow this to
happen we've not heard a lot coming out
of Washington DC about how to handle
this in a big in a big way a big
coordinated way I think it's Fallen to
our mayor to figure all this out and and
work with the governor and others in the
state of New York but in fact it is a
mess and as we get to this season of uh
this is probably the first summer in
three years that we're actually going to
have normalcy in our city in our state
and we are concerned about the influx of
folks taking up limited Hotel space uh
now that we're into this almost into the
summer season you know Tom it you
mentioned that Congress should do
something about it and that may be part
of it but there's also executive branch
decisions that are being made that
facilitate this this wasn't happening
three years ago for you years ago this
is something that's clearly changed what
I mean would you be for actual
enforcement at the border to prevent it
at the source
I think there needs to be a
comprehensive immigration policy across
our country north south east and west
that allows people to come in in a
metered kind of a controlled way heaven
knows that we need we need workers to uh
to do some of the do some of the jobs
that lots of these folks uh normally do
but without any kind of coordinated
control a lot of Americans I mean I bet
but there also is plenty of evidence
that bring in if the the workers
argument drives down wages for everybody
else and if you're not here legally how
do you protect companies hiring illegals
or or minors in that process so is this
really about Labor
a good point about that because right
now there's no real process in place to
allow the folks that have come up coming
up here to have the ability to be able
to legally work in in New York and in
the U.S and that that's a problem that
has to be solved as well
um you know we were decimated in New
York with thousands and thousands of of
restaurants and other places closed
we're just starting to get back and many
of the folks that worked in those
Industries no longer choose to work in
hospitality and in restaurants and I'm
sure if those folks that are being bused
up here unfortunately unfortunately
blessed up here could find positions in
those in those roles if they were given
the proper clearance to be able to do so
uh it just feels like a solution to a
problem that shouldn't exist in the
first place as you're pushing American
taxpayers out of jobs and making the
American dream less accessible for the
people already just think about the cost
I mean the numbers that we've heard
lately are like six to seven million
dollars a day just for the City of New
York that's absurd number and the FEDS
ought to definitely step in to prevent
this kind of uh onslaught of folks
coming up
um well up to New York City the feds are
facilitating the onslaught right now
they're the ones helping and speeding up
the process of illegals coming to this
town and others across the country Tom
Gretch thank you for your time
thank you very much I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis